The Push to Hub API.
Let's have a look at the push_to_hub API.
You will need to be logged in with your Hugging
Face account, which you can do by executing
this first cell or typing huggingface-cli
login in a terminal.
Just enter your username and password and
click login, which will store an authentication
token in the cache of the machine you're using.
Now, let's launch the fine-tuning of a BERT
model on the GLUE COLA dataset.
We won't go over the fine-tuning code because
you can find it in any Transformers tutorial,
or by looking at the videos linked below.
What interests us here, is how we can leverage
the Model Hub during training.
This is done with the push_to_hub=True passed
in your TrainingArguments . This will automatically
upload your model to the Hub each time it
is saved (so every epoch in our case), which
allows you to resume training from a different
machine if the current one gets interrupted.
The model will be uploaded in your namespace,
with the name of the output directory as a
repository name.
You can pick another name by passing it to
the hub_model_id argument, and you can also
push inside an organization you are a member
of by passing a full repository name.
With that done, we can just launch training
and wait a little bit.
Note that the model is pushed asynchronously,
meaning that the training continues while
your model is uploaded to the Hub.
When your first commit is finished, you can
go inspect your model on the Hub and even
start playing with its inference widget while
it's training!
There is something wrong with the labels,
but we will fix this later on in this video.
When the training is finished, we should do
one last push with trainer.push_to_hub for
two reasons.
One this will make sure we are uploading the
final version of our models if we didn't already
(for instance if we saved every n steps instead
of every epoch).
Two, this will draft a model card that will
be the landing page of your model repo.
Going back to the model page, you can see
the Trainer included some metadata that is
interpreted by the Hugging Face website in
the model card.
On top of informations about the training,
the intermediate results or the hyperparameter
used, we get the values of the metrics automatically
displayed in a small widget, and a link to
a leaderboard in Paper with Code.
The Tensorboard runs have also been pushed
to this repo, and we can look at them directly
from the Model Hub.
If you were not using the Trainer API to fine-tune
your model, you can use the push_to_hub method
on the model and tokenizer directly.
Let's test this to fix our labels in the inference
widget!
The inference widget was using default names
for labels because we did not indicate the
correspondence between integers and label
names.
We can fix in the configuration by setting
the label2id and id2label fields to their
proper value then we can push the fixed config
to our repo using the push_to_hub method.
Once this is done and we can check on the
website the model is now showing the proper
labels!
Now that the model is on the hub, we can use
it from anywhere with the from_pretrained
method.
We just have to use the identifier from the
hub and we can see that the model configuration
and weights are automatically downloaded.
We can use this model as we would any other
Transformers model, for instance by loading
it in a pipeline.
Try the push_to_hub API on your next training
to easily share your model with the rest of
the world!